we're gonna take a look at how much
money you would have made if you
invested 1 000
into bitcoin one year ago
five years ago and 10 years ago and
we'll compare that what if you put that
money into the s p 500 which i'm a big
advocate of anyway
here's the article according to cnbc
bitcoin has surged in popularity
naturally since 2017 when it rallied
from 900 to almost 20 000 less than a
year i got in basically in 2017 fyi oh
okay that's when i got it okay
but it has become known
much for its plunges
as much for its rallies right we've seen
it up and down it's crypto it's um
it's uh
it's up and down yeah it is what it is
just i said something about uh
what'd i say it's like crypto's like my
ex-girlfriend it's uh
you never know what you're gonna get
over there anyway
anyway
uh it's seen the value plummet on
several occasions we all know it's
volatile it's volatile it's risky uh but
with risk comes reward and it's the same
reason that it's valuable risk and
reward yeah but there's no central
authority it's decentralized there's
nothing that can intervene if the market
tanks there's no one bailing you out
there's no bailouts with bitcoin no
bitcoin bailouts that's not happening
right so this article is based on
the current this is this article is
based on bitcoin was at 40 000. just
keep in mind right just from a
perspective standpoint bitcoin could be
up at 45 today go down to 30 today right
but anyway so looking for some stability
the line i was looking for was bitcoins
as unstable as my ex-girlfriend there it
was i don't want to butcher that anyway
um we're still friends though we're good
okay in case we're watching anyway one
year ago
based on one year
growth 250. now if you're getting if
you're making 10 on your money 20 of
your money you're winning
we're talking 250 percent in the past
year have you invested a thousand
dollars in bitcoin you know how much
you'd have uh how much 3 600 bucks okay
nothing crazy nothing crazy nothing
crazy too much thousand dollars is now 3
600 bucks okay okay
five years ago oh god when bitcoin was
um
at that time 650 bucks a coin apparently
it has grown
5 800 over the last five years if you
invested a thousand bucks
in
2016 were in 2021 so five years ago
that a thousand bucks would now be
sixty thousand dollars
sixty thousand
okay then 60 g's okay now go back 10
years to 2001 two years after bitcoin
and satoshi nakamoto really was created
this was after 2008 so in 2009 the cost
of one bitcoin was 14
right so if you invested
a thousand dollars into bitcoin it has
grown
278 000
and your thousand dollar investment
drumroll wait for it would now be worth
2.7
million
dollars
2.7 so if you're that dude
i don't know what this bitcoin is a
thousand bucks screw it whatever 2.7
million there is someone out there maybe
watching right now that was like
you know there's stories out there it's
like i was given a bitcoin yeah but i
spent it on dinner yeah there's stories
out yeah there was that guy that bought
the pizza right there exactly it was a
pizza story i think that's what i
thought
i bought i bought a pizza pie with it
yeah it could have been
a couple million bucks at this yeah
ridiculous anyway that's
so now by comparison let's say i i'm a
big advocate of just index investing s p
500 um
a thousand dollar investment into the s
p 500 this is
um
over the last one five and ten years
for the past one year you'd be up 39
since last year 123
since 2016 and 305 percent since 2011.
so if you invest in s p you're still
winning
like you you can invest in the s p get a
401k get a roth ira get an index fund
mutual fund boom now you're invested in
the s p 500. we talked at the beginning
of the show we're going to build your
wealth buddy okay build your damn wealth
you better get yeah
[Laughter]
anyway here are the lessons
you can't time the market
bitcoin's been up it's been down the s p
stock market it's been up it's been down
right this is why i always say it's not
about day trading it's about
decade trading
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken